fixer l'âge de départ à la retraite a
toujours été un casse tête comme on va
vivre plus longtemps
il va falloir travailler un peu plus
longtemps reculer cet âge fait hurler
les ans encore travailler plus quand ça
va pas leur bordel quand d'autres sont
prêts à exercer leur fonction plus
longtemps à 60 ans on a encore beaucoup
de choses à donner
alors travaillons nous trop ou pas assez
longtemps
essayons d'y voir plus clair si le
compagnon de travail on s'en va
premier constat malgré les lois
successives
l'âge effectif de départ à la retraite
n'a pas beaucoup bougé depuis les années
60 il a même légèrement diminué passant
de 63,7 à 62,7 ans en 2018 pour autant
si les gouvernements successifs ont
voulu reculer le départ en retraite
c'est entre autres parce que nous vivons
plus longtemps dès lors que l'on vit
plus longtemps parfois beaucoup plus
longtemps
on devra travailler aussi un peu plus
en un demi siècle l'espérance de vie des
femmes a atteint 85,3 en 79,4 ans pour
les hommes
alors en mettant nos courbes en regard
saynètes nous vivons plus longtemps
qu'avant et travaillons un peu moins de
s'arrêter le plus tôt possible
en profiter mais ce n'est pas aussi
simple car si nous vivons plus vieux
nous ne gardons pas pour autant notre
pleine capacité c'est l'un des arguments
des opposants recul de l'âge de départ
en retraite
d'abord en vie plus longtemps les
tracasser pour y voir plus clair il faut
s'intéresser à un autre indice
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé depuis
2004 pour les femmes elle est passée de
64,2 à 64,9 ans et pour les hommes de
61,5 à 62,6 en le constat dans le temps
l'âge de départ en retraite quoi ainsi
de plus ou moins avec l'âge moyen où
nous sommes encore en bonne santé en
2018 cela dit les français sont partis à
la retraite seulement quelques mois
avant d'atteindre cet âge
[Musique]